it's a thursday edition of
p-f-t-o-t
i know there's no pft live for which
this can be pftot but you know the drill
by now we've got another week or so of
this before pft live returns on july 29
and on that day the nfl and the nfl
players association will be getting
together for the next time to continue
their discussions toward a new
collective bargaining agreement this is
a strange development from wednesday
because the two sides were due to get
together for three days of cba
discussions
the first day wednesday abruptly mid to
late afternoon the two sides issued a
joint statement indicating that the
talks are already over that they're very
productive beneficial to both sides but
they don't have anything further to talk
about they're going to cancel thursday
and friday and get back together again
reportedly on july 29 and
i
i understand that the news is the news
and the joint statement is the joint
statement and we can either take it at
face value or
we can probe a little bit more deeply
and i choose to probe a little bit more
deeply and wonder what in the world
really is going on here you've got
the nfl
wanting to get a deal done
by the start of the regular season more
on that coming up in a moment
and you've got some real issues that you
need to work through if they're ever
going to get a deal done yeah there are
some
incidental issues little things that
they need to talk through but the big
issues and the two big issues in my view
are how the revenue ultimately is going
to be split and how much money gets
taken off the top for stadium credits
before they do the split because
obviously the more money the nfl siphons
off the top to pay for stadium
construction and renovation the less
money is available to split between the
two sides those are the two issues
and
now i look at it this way
if we couch this as an extension well
it's not really an extension in the
sense that both sides say hey everything
is working well let's just keep doing
what we're doing they're coming to the
bargaining table and they are
focusing on big questions like whether
into what extent the current revenue
split should be changed whether to what
extent the current allowances for
stadium credits should be adjusted these
are significant issues and at some point
there's going to be
some acrimony there's going to be some
hard feelings there's going to be some
tough arguments and moments in
the negotiating room and i'm starting to
think
that the two sides are creating a false
impression that everything is well
just because they realize it's not in
anyone's interests
to create the impression that things
aren't going well
that if they can maintain this idea that
it's all very smooth it's all very
simple it's all very normal while they
fight it out privately
then
the football fan doesn't freak out about
the possibility of another lockout now i
don't know that that's sustainable and i
i kind of wonder
and this is just my idea this is just my
thought based upon the circumstances
that they got together on
wednesday and they began for the first
time
to talk about real issues and realized
well we got some real issues here
before we spend the next three days
beating the hell out of each other let's
just press pause on this and let's get
back together on july 29 coincidentally
or not when the
members of the executive committee who
have jobs with nfl teams are in training
camp and that reduces the overall
potential for friction the fewer people
you have negotiating
the less the chance that one person is
going to get upset by something that
someone the other side may have to say
so i i think that
that before they got to the point
where the crap hit the fan on wednesday
they recognized
let's call this productive let's call
this beneficial let's call it a day
let's not get together thursday or
friday let's get together on the 29th
day of july and
maybe that's the moment when they'll
bloody each other up a little bit but
act to the rest of us like everything is
still going very well now i've already
mentioned
the idea that the nfl wants to get a cba
in place by the start of the regular
season and something very interesting
happened yesterday because it was just
last week that the commissioner roger
goodell sat down with cnbc and among
other things he confirmed that it is
certainly our intent to have a new cba
with the union in place by the start of
the regular season we had reported that
weeks before no one had ever disputed it
and here's the commissioner a week ago
confirming that that is what the nfl
wants
yesterday
in the aftermath of this one day only
when three days were set aside
bargaining session with the joint
statement everything is fine
mike garifolo who works for the nfl and
and i know that
people who work at nfl media don't
really like it when i say they work for
the nfl but spoiler alert they do
when gary follows says that the nfl
really isn't pushing all that hard to
get the deal done by the start of the
regular season
just a week ago the commissioner said
that's our intent that's certainly our
intent so
what what's going on here and
you know the bigger picture reality and
i'll try to choose my words a little bit
carefully
i just think that if you're going to go
to nfl network or nfl.com for news about
the nfl nflpa collective bargaining
agreement discussions you have to view
that news and any opinions articulated
at those locations through the prism
that
you're getting it all from nfl employees
and
you know if your sources in the league
office are telling you hey this is
what's going on are you going to
say that you know what maybe that's not
really what's going on maybe they're not
telling us the truth are you really
going to do that are you going to impugn
the credibility
and the truthfulness of people who like
you are having their paychecks signed by
roger goodell or
are you going to impugn the credibility
and the
overall trustworthiness of the
commissioner if he talks about these
issues and maybe the circumstances
suggest that something else is going on
so anyway
here's the point i don't know how
carefully i chose my words but i don't
care here's the
point i think the nfl does want
to get a cba in place
by the start of the regular season
but they're starting to recognize it's
not going to be easy to do and sure if
they can get one done on their terms by
the start of the regular season fine but
i don't think they're going to get one
done on their terms by the start of the
regular season because the union is
smart enough to realize hey if the nfl
wants to get this done by the start of
the regular season and we don't really
care we've got leverage we we can say
you have to give us a premium you have
to give us more than you otherwise would
give us because you're the ones who want
to get this done so now i think the nfl
is trying to back off from this idea
that they want to get it done because
they're recognizing yeah the union's
smart enough to know that the price goes
up on a new cba if we're the ones who
want to get this done by the start of
the regular season and they really don't
care one way or the other whether or not
the deal is done by the time the packers
and the bears kick off on nbc on the
evening of september 5. the denver
broncos have kicked off training camp
they're the first team to get together
and it looked like quarterback drew lock
the 42nd overall pick in the draft was
going to be a hold out and i guess
technically he was for a little bit but
they got that deal done yesterday
afternoon now there was a report that
drew locks agents were looking for a
quarterback premium i'm told that they
really weren't they were pushing they
were negotiating but they weren't going
to hold out and see the one thing about
all this that we need to keep in mind
the player ultimately decides when he's
going to show up or not show up and
sometimes the player defers completely
and totally to the agent and sometimes
the player says look i don't care what
you do do the best possible deal you can
but i'm showing up i want to be there i
want to practice and i want to compete
and prepare myself to be the starting
quarterback
whether i beat out joe flacco or whether
joe flacco gets injured and i need to be
ready to go so
you know i think an effort was made to
maybe get him a little bit more given
that he is a quarterback and given that
most people thought he should have been
a first-round pick and he slid down to
pick number 42 and you know the agent's
doing the best possible deal but they
ultimately got the best offer they could
on the table which involved some workout
bonuses in 2021 and 2022 that shifts
some money around gets him some money
sooner than otherwise would have gotten
it and you know at the end of the day
drew lock still gets the same dollar
figure he would have gotten because
these deals are now all formulaic it's
all determined ahead of time what you're
going to get based upon your slot there
isn't a whole lot that can be negotiated
cash flow guarantee etc and at the end
of the day some improved cash flow for
drew lock but the good news for the
broncos he's in camp he's ready to go
and they'll they'll see whether or not
they've finally taken care of their
quarterback issues the la chargers have
a running back issue that is still
lingering melvin gordon wants more money
he most recently said his teammates have
his back well i can think of one
teammate that that doesn't have his back
and that teammate would be
uh
austin eckler the backup running back
who stands to become
the
the number one running back if
melvin gordon does indeed make good on
his threat to hold out and and when you
look at the drop-off is there even a
drop off from melvin going to austin
echo i really don't know peter schaefer
an agent who has represented multiple
running backs over the course of his
career and he's spearheading this idea
to reverse the devaluing of the running
back position i
you know his argument is there are
certain running backs that will force a
defense to do something differently i
don't know that melvin gordon is a guy
that forces a defense to do something
differently than what they're already
going to do i think a team that's
getting ready to play the chargers is
going to approach it the same way if
gordon's the running back versus austin
eckler period you're not reconfiguring
the defense to stop gordon anymore that
you're then you're reconfiguring the
defense to stop eckler so
look
gordon needs to be careful here and and
let me reiterate
i love it when a guy stands up to the
system i love it when a guy tries to
disrupt the way that nfl teams try to
dictate
the way things should be done
but you got to have leverage you got to
have good standing you've got to be a
guy who the team says oh crap we can't
go forward without this player
a point i made yesterday at pft anthony
lin the head coach the chargers a former
running backs coach a former nfl running
back
i think he knows special when he sees it
and if anthony lynn believed that melvin
gordon's absence was in some way going
to derail the fate and the fortunes of
the 2019 la chargers we probably
wouldn't be at this point where melvin
gordon has to threaten a holdout by now
anthony lynn would have used his
leverage leverage he surely has amassed
based upon his great performance as the
coach of the team so far and stood up in
a meeting room with tom telesco the gm
of the team or with the spanos family
and said we got to pay melvin gordon i
know a great running back when i see one
we have a great running back let's pay
him that hasn't happened or if it's
happened anthony lynn has failed to get
the message across either way
melvin gordon
could end up being the next maurice
jones drew and not in a good way because
it was in 2012 that jones drew held out
for all of training camp all the
pre-season it was at labor day weekend
he realized you know what they're not
giving me a new contract they're not
going to change anything i better just
show up and go back and play football
and that could be what melvin gordon
does and if that's the end result nobody
benefits from that least of which is
melvin gordon because he'll be starting
the season woefully unprepared relative
to how prepared he could have been if he
would have been there for training camp
in the preseason one guy who says that
he will be showing up for the start of
training camp as falcons receiver julio
jones now the falcons report on the 21st
so that's just a few days away they're
getting ready to face the broncos in the
hall of fame game they get extra time
for training camp but that shortens the
deadline for when jones needs to be
there and more importantly when the
falcons need to get a deal done with
jones and look what the falcons have
done recently they did a beat the clock
deal with grady jarrett on monday before
the deadline came and went for signing
franchise tag players to long-term deals
and then on wednesday dion jones gets a
new contract so
does julio jones get his new contract
before the 21st he he has he has said
hey arthur blank the owner of the team
has given me his word that we're going
to get this done well it's one thing for
the falcons to want to get it done it's
another thing for the falcons to give in
to whatever it is that julio jones wants
and and that's the bottom line here it's
not a blank check hey yeah we'll gladly
sign you to a new contract
if you accept our terms but we're not
going to give in to what you want simply
because you want that much money we want
to give you a new deal you don't want to
take the deal we want to give you so
let's keep an eye on this one last year
remember it looked like julio jones was
going to hold out they moved some money
around to placate him but the thinking
always was by this year he would get
that next contract and the challenge for
the falcons is very simple
the falcons know that they've probably
already gotten the best of julio jones
so
how much do you pay a guy
for what he's already done that runs
counter to everything we've heard about
the nfl in the last 25 years with the
advent of the salary cap and free agency
the nfl became a what have you done for
me lately league or more accurately what
are you doing for me right now and what
can i expect you to do for me tomorrow
that's what teams pay for julio jones i
think to a certain degree wants to get
paid for past performance once they get
paid for the fact that maybe he hasn't
gotten paid as much as he should have
gotten paid during those years where he
was truly in his prime now look he may
still be very well in his prime he could
be the best receiver in the nfl this
season but
he's getting closer and closer to the
edge of the cliff and the falcons don't
want to put themselves in position where
they have paid a ton of money to a guy
who isn't performing up to
that dollar figure that julio jones
apparently wants so we'll see in the
next few days whether or not they get
that deal done and we'll see you
tomorrow for a friday edition of pftot
another edition of pft pm coming this
week i'll probably do it on friday
afternoon answer all your questions
heading into really the last
semi-slow weekend of the off-season
because by the following weekend all
training camps will be open and the
following weekend after that is the hall
of fame festivities and then off we go
with the nfl's 100th season so thanks as
always for some of your time we'll do
this again on friday
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports